going back to that reel i hear a lot of
actors say you know what i'm having
trouble getting this spot from this one
director for this one project whatever
oh did you encounter any of that oh how
did you work through oh
i'm so glad you asked that let's i'm
going to be very
candid about this
one of the hardest things to do as an
actor especially beginning
and you're doing student projects or
independent projects is to get
footage from directors
and there were times when i didn't
receive footage
i'd work two weeks three weeks you know
long days on a project
and they wouldn't give me my footage and
i was seeing a pattern of this
especially in the first few years of
doing this and i was like oh no
no this is i would send
a barrage of emails phone calls texts
and be like
you owe me this footage i did this for
almost like low to no pay
what i did this for was experience and
for you to give me my damn footage
i would harass people oh i would say i'm
coming to your house
and i'm going to take it off your hard
drive because they owe you that
you know directors you know i love
directors but some of them take
advantage of actors
especially if they're not paying you
they're using your your talent for their
film
that is your work though and they owe
you that
so get your footage you deserve it
you earn it and you need to use it to
show people it's not going to do
anything on someone's hard drive
nice yeah i feel very strongly about
this
because i've had lots of run-ins with
directors and that's your work
i mean that is your work get it and use
it